Oh  the Giants from the hills would collect  four keys and now the very heavens  scooped up let me introduce the Giants  from the hills something here is not  right something about you can you not  see it that Mirage with you has been  corrupted I think you got the wrong idea  there pal Barnes I have awaited this day  a thousand years  did you just add a digit what fees they  must be desperate to take this realm  away from me  lucky for you I would be delighted to  take it off your hands  think about it don't you dare lead us  down the wrong path how far mom right  Jeff we're back accept it I will not  and it's all my fault with these freaks  have ruined grimoire I have to pay for  it all you have to stop you mustn't  fight you know you want to but you  simply can't